this is Startalk some great science
fiction storytelling involves power of
the mind telekinesis
you know mind control mind reading is is
that is anyone working on this is it in
the future
or is it just a pipe dream yeah so well
there's studies let's say something like
mind reading their studies now where you
you put someone in a scanner and you
show them different pictures or even
movies and you see what the sort of
neural signature is of that and then you
again put them in the scanner the
experimenter doesn't know what they're
looking at they're only reading out
their brain activation and they could
very reliably predict what the person is
seeing and then if you take that as step
back and you can even look at what a
person is imagining so over time the
more precise this gets I can definitely
envision someone just reading someone's
neural sort of activation and and
predicting what it is they're thinking
about so you'd have to walk around some
kind of neuro map riser so that you can
detect if someone is being turned on or
turned off or be highly useful socially
yeah yeah you're describing like a super
EXTREME guesstimation like being not
mind eating you're just talking about a
very very very you could be wrong well
better the better that's not the more we
understand about the brain the closer
you will be to getting right but
successful charlatans or so-called
mentalists or magicians they have
disability at some very reasonable rate
probably through facials go ahead well
yeah there's there's a lot there's a lot
of subtlety that that's not mind reading
right that's a very subtle fine-tuning
into body language gesturing shifting of
basically the air around people but
there's nothing magical mystical about
it your grandmother is here and she
agrees I'm getting something I'm getting
does anyone who came in on heaven on the
trouble with their whiteness a white mom
but-but-but I'm sorry if we take what
you're talking about Heather maybe 10
steps further is it possible in the
future it would be possible to kind of
record your consciousness and then
market that as I would be able to live
as you for a day
my bite through through a sort of kind
of VR virtual reality playback I don't
know if you could ever that's a very
just say yes awful question I tell you
what I would do I would buy that URL
right now man ground floor but actually
another study that that I'm involved in
we're doing something called hyper
scanning or dual scanning where we can
scan two people at the same time having
an interaction and kind of seeing what's
happening in the space between two
people because as I said before I can
never get into your brain I really know
what you're thinking and that's what
communication is it's about the space
between and now we're seeing what's
happening in your brain when you're
actually really taking in what I'm
saying and vice versa and also much as
you know as scientists I'm sure we'd all
agree yeah there are things that we
can't see and that we can't understand
but there are also things that we know
now as scientists things like pheromones
there are things that occur for example
between two people that are not
necessarily detectable in all the other
ways we're looking but there's something
that happens that again we don't need to
write off as magical and mystical we may
not be able to measure it yet but yes I
think we'll get there in more ways okay
so let me add let's we'll end the show
with this with this exploration does if
you want Heather you're on really there
I say dangerous territory because the
more you know what the brain is and what
it does as a scientist what any
scientist wanted to wants to do at the
end of the day is control it yeah you
want it you want that's that's the
evidence that you know what it is you're
doing you want to make predictions make
predictions have those predictions come
true and say I know how this thing works
so if the brain is your laboratory and
you say oh here's this this I've just
discovered what makes two people fall in
love
now you make a love potion number nine
and you control people's behavior and
conduct do you have another team of
ethicists behind you looking over your
shoulder at your conduct yes it's the
CIA yeah there's a whole field of
neuroethics
which are talking about issues but yes I
mean ultimately what we're going is from
correlation to causation when I say
we're going into the brain and
implanting electrodes for a good cause
to treat psychiatric illness we're
controlling emotions and you know if
somebody whose emotions that are
socially regressive yeah so but you can
actually yeah I mean if we know exactly
what the right formula is for sale of I
mean people will you can stimulate an
emotion in someone and they'll label it
as love I mean so so but but no one's
there overlooking my shoulder saying you
know there's an IRB there's a board that
like IRB the yeah an institutional
review board yes that makes sure that
you don't make people fall in love when
they're not supposed okay exactly feel
super safe okay so so but the day would
surely come where you can make someone
smarter if they can afford to pay you
you could cure them if they can afford
that you have all kinds of neurological
disorders I'm just wondering what is
what is the dystopic future of this and
what is the U topic utopic future of
this well one one issue is that it could
be that only people who can afford let's
say the neural implants get them and
then they have an advantage it's just
like and then everybody will have to so
like performance-enhancing drugs you
know in sports the reason they outlaw
them is because if one person has it
they have the advantage everyone else
has to do with this name with mental
illness right in terms of access to
mental health care and mental you know
exactly I mean once one person has a
mental illness everybody else no but
we're Network sort where I think what
you're getting at were there there's a
dangerous possibility of sort of
narrowing the field of who is well who
is smart who is desirable who is
accessible who gets access to care that
not to bring it down at the end but that
could be danger and so so let me ask
each one of you
the scariest future of neuroscience you
couldn't think of okay we ends on a
positive part enough okay okay so great
what is it rip ah what is the UH you
work in this field what is 50 years in
the future what is that world gifted to
us by you and your research colleagues
50 years from now what is that well what
I would hope is that we can really have
a full-scale map of the human brain
going all the way from the genome to
function and to mind and brain and once
we have this full map of the brain and
how it works then we can help prevent
things like Alzheimer's so rather than
looking at treatments we're going to
look at prevention you know if you can
go in and tweak the genome a bit so that
people don't get these kinds of mental
disorders to begin with and we don't
even have to worry so much about the
treatment side of things so that would
be wonderful so you can you treat the
genome in an adult you treat the Jim in
an adult and then that it fixes their
brain as an adult that would be great if
we can do that yeah if we can even do it
in the in an adult to change it right
yeah gotta ask though from an
evolutionary standpoint why is it that a
genetic that mental illness persists if
it's really especially dangerous
wouldn't it have been eliminated from
the gene pool so I suspect it's not in
the biggest picture that deadly to have
a mental illness if it's manageable
that is to say germs and parasites are
much more likely to kill you than being
mentally
different and so I just wonder about
this whole thing when you go to predict
the future without taking to account
let's say the flu that killed more
people in 1918 than World War one did
and so the other thing is this is these
questions I think are really only access
only useful to a society that can afford
it right the people that are more
successful at having an overall health
in their tribe or their society might do
better than it wasn't they can just in
terms of quality of life work there are
two things there one is that certain
things do persist like for example being
a sensation seeker being really
impulsive though that's a quality that
got people out there and you know
discovered America right these kinds of
traits which we might call by the way
that probably killed more people than
who actually survived domestic ability
and mental illness right right right
yeah I mean there's not and that's to
say that everything with mental illness
there are some positive things about
being at the extreme ends of what we
consider to be normal there is no such
thing as normal but but what studies do
show is that the most amount of of any
disease cancer you know all sorts of
physiologic diseases the thing that
causes people the most poorest lowest
quality of life and distress or mental
illness because they don't die from it
but they have to suffer with their life
and often they have children and pass on
genes that maybe predisposing to to
future mental illnesses it's a really
sad discussion okay we get it we got to
wrap this up so so so my really
depressing though yeah all right do it
what what can what's in your future
personally or in the field of
neuroscience video yeah your personal
future yeah oh you're looking at it okay
no I mean like whatever I have this book
it's called my name's vegan table I work
on the Big Bang Theory and I have two
kids and that's my life but 50 years ago
Sonic's gonna be doing for us 50 was he
said no no I was a good listener that X
sorry what did you say let me let me
offer some sort of concluding remarks
here I think we you know I study the
universe and the interesting thing is
that there's this universe inside our
heads that is perhaps less well known
than the universe that extends back to
the Big Bang and time and and in space
and so I it's curious maybe the big
challenge here is studying your using
your own brain to study your brain
you're not there you're not some other
entity studying the brain and that
prevents some questions perhaps from
even being asked because you know you
don't even know the right question
because the brain is asking the question
about the brain and
and Carl Sagan is famous for the saying
that humans conscious humans are a way
for the universe to know itself and no
we're not the universe we're in the
universe and we use our brain power to
decode the universe I'm just I'm
intrigued by the fact that the real
future here might just be in our minds
and maybe we will learn what questions
we're not asking it and those are the
questions that keep me going every day
because that's that's the future of
discovery in any field so join me giving
a very warm thank you to this brilliant
great job you guys
cool
we its Q&A time we have some microphones
on the aisles we can bring up the house
lights maybe two half and what we prefer
is just to find one person to direct the
question to because of all 12 of us
answer it takes all night so if you can
be specific about it sir you're up front
hey how are you doing hello um so you
talked a little bit about the idea of
there's these people superhumans
right and so there are people out there
who have what I think is called savant
syndrome who have some kind of amazing
mental abilities they can they can like
learn new languages in a week or do
really rapid calculation so what's
different about these people's brains is
this something we all have inherently
able in our brains and could we hack it
to enable that ability
well I recognize that question you're
the guy who won this contest aren't you
yes you wanna cry ask thank you
oh you okay and they put your first date
- oh they told me to Russia excellent
excellent okay a great question I think
you know we all want some of that
ability right so so what's up with that
yeah how can we all become magic sort of
all answer if I think what savant is
what they seem to be wired slightly
differently and so they seemed up these
usually these isolated areas of
specialization sometimes at the cost of
other parts of the brain development of
other parts of the brain so it's not
necessarily great a good thing to be
very very good at just one thing and at
the sex at the cost of other things and
the only way I think we can enhance our
cognitive abilities is with working at
it it's a anything like with you know
losing weight you have to work at it so
I don't think there's a sort of magic
pill or but but it has to do with the
way that their brains are wired slightly
differently okay so using the word
wiring so in the future you can adjust
the wiring if you have a if you have a
if you have a savant is there is there
an ethical question about whether you
would change that about that person yeah
I think there is I think it's it's it
any it's would like anything even with a
psychopath
they don't come in gestures
Psychopaths they may be a way you know
so if they're not a threats other people
are if they're not in distress I don't
think that we should go around just
changing people for the sake of it
question here yes yes so since we have
the comedian's here I don't know if you
guys have thought a lot about the
intersection between comedy and
neuroscience I have yes
yeah I wrote a paper on the physiology
of laughter in college right yeah so
actually he did those ooh yeah it was
all wrong but all right perfect so um
you know these guys are up here
providing great like comedic
interjection and not everyone can do
that like not every brain works that way
so maybe we could hear from like one
comedian and one neuroscientist like why
or how about a neuroscientist who is a
comedian I can't ask all of you so yes
no come on so Maya go Wyatt liar why are
they funny why are you I don't know if I
can answer that but I can say that I can
I add that when she wouldn't couldn't
say this about herself on the Big Bang
Theory her timing is impeccable
Yeah right from 1991 to 1994 she was
blossom on the show yes I mean and you
were the young Bette Midler it was in
the rose yes Pete you're feeding speech
again um no I mean I'm happy to let you
guys also speak to it I mean in terms of
what's funny or not you we want you to
speak up no but in terms of what's funny
and why are things funny there is a
really interesting field of sort of
understanding the the timing of how you
know complicated it is
it's complicated social interaction but
I think for me as as an actor and as a
scientist what I'm aware of is what we
constantly do is work constantly
scanning and tracking and it's people
can do it better than others you know
stand-ups can do something that I can't
do right I can't do improv there's
there's a different set of skills that
that actors and performers have but you
know the joke that we tend to be
neurotic that we tend to be constantly
looking to make someone feel something
is a very complicated thing about being
an actor and I didn't think about it as
much when I was younger but but when
when you meet other actors and when you
talk about process which a lot of people
laugh they figure like we're paid to be
funny or were paid to make people
believe something it's a very
complicated process by which I need to
make you feel something I need to make
you believe something and I need every
single person to feel that so if you're
a stand-up you're working with a room of
people when I work in front of a live
audience I need everyone to feel
something and it's a really complicated
interaction especially if you work with
a live audience it's very different than
then not because it is a constant
tracking you have your Archimedean
subjects of your well yeah actually so
this is really exciting stuff this is a
new era of research we're going to is
actually the neural basis of creativity
and improvisation and so what we find is
that whether it's jazz improv comedy
improv there's a certain neural
signature involved when people are
improvising so you can put people in a
scanner and you can even freestyle
rappers right so you give them a
memorized rap and then they can
freestyle or you give a musician a
memorized piece or improv and when
they're improvising what they find is
that a part of the prefrontal cortex the
medial prefrontal cortex becomes extra
activated and that has to do with
internally generated ideas and the
dorsal lateral part of the prefrontal
cortex becomes deactivated and that as
do a sort of self-awareness and
monitoring your behavior so you almost
go into this free-flowing state if you
become high too aware you mess up you're
not good at improvising you have to kind
of lose yourself so to speak not the
neuroimaging shows I have a follow-up is
there any connection between improv and
optimism uh I don't know actually wait
one of the studies showed actually one
of the study showed that that when they
were improvising they had increased
activation of the amygdala which could
be related to positive feelings that's
your your brain part kind of my thing
that's interesting to know all right
right here sir yeah hi um
every Christian actually had a couple of
questions but then when you guys
mentioned um eugenics that's kind of
your day what's your question Himmler
kind of shades my question isn't it oh
good I was actually all I could think
about was the movie idiocracy I don't
know if any of you guys have seen that
geography um it's kind of a scary look
at what might happen if if dumb people
keep breeding thank you yes
luckily my guys are like if you know
okay so my question is um to the neuro
folks over there um uh I don't know if
you've seen anything going in that
direction or not or have you seen a
genetic predisposition predisposition in
society to become idiots I didn't see
the movie so I can't speak to that well
uh this is gonna be I'm trying to be
like sort of PC well one of the one
thing is that with with evolution in the
past right if it was survival of the
fittest
then those who just couldn't make it
couldn't make it they would die out and
then there would be certain traits that
would have evolved and survived but but
now we have all sorts of ways to keep
those people exactly
shop so who knows what's gonna happen if
we were in Washington DC to be a GSI
joke right there our question right here
I've got kind of a in depth and specific
question gets to the scientists and I
guess to the neuroscientists here based
on quantum theories of the mind what's
your take on the idea that constant
consciousness originates at the quantum
level and if you're familiar with
Schrodinger's equation the affair very
fact that observing something changes
the outcome so the mind observing
consciousness what's your guys's take on
that yeah I can offer something on that
as well so a quantitative night dad
quantum physics has sort of mysterious
properties that are real but they defy
anything your five senses or more have
ever experienced in your life so you say
well that's weird
but it's real it happens particles pop
in and out of existence
you you look at it and then it changes
into something else this is that this is
the behavior of the universe on the
smallest scale because there has all
these mysterious properties what I have
found in my experience watching people
think about the world is they have this
urge to insert quantum physics where
there's something where they don't
otherwise understand what it is so we
don't really understand consciousness
quantum physics must be at work all
right so it's this yeah and in fact the
more they invoke quantum physics that's
the evidence that they know least about
what it is they're talking about well I
met this and I don't know what I'm
talking about
I think the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle I mean I I do appreciate this
notion that any observation of something
alters what it is how we perceive it we
describe it I believe that
when I observe you you don't pop into a
different quantum state you are
macroscopic entity large things six foot
seven average out the hot these
principles so that we have a macroscopic
world that lends itself to macroscopic
discussions just take you to sit down
you just want to tell them if we were
the size of particles yes me beaming
eyes at you with the light would pop you
into some other part of the universe yes
but you're big so it doesn't happen
again shut up is that a faster okay okay
okay yeah but it would be cool it would
be cool if you if we were like particle
size and you walked through a doorway
okay
you would diffract okay cuz that's
little height though I mean it'd be
funny if if Planck's constant we're much
larger than it is weird stuff would
happen all the time okay so yes I just
bring us the brain for a second the okay
so there's a I just want to diffuse this
theory cuz everyone I always get this
question about the quantum theory and
there's this Roger Penrose who's a
mathematician at Oxford and and Stuart
Hameroff who whose anesthesiologist they
came up with this theory of quantum the
quantum theory of consciousness
basically saying that at some level at
the at the structural level of the
neuron is where these quantum effects
can sort of take place and that's where
consciousness lies and the rest of it
but but there's no evidence for that and
also the temperatures at which these
effects would have to occur they'd have
to be cooler than the temperature that
the brain is currently at so so there's
a lot of things that go against this
idea but again people tend to want to
put together something mysterious with
something else mysterious but as far as
we know from the field of neuroscience
there's no evidence can I ask a
follow-up question about this okay oh
it's quick but go now this might be like
here
is very polite how do you get that I'm
cutting the line so I come on yeah
doesn't this imply this idea does that
imply then that consciousness has mass
and do we know that to be true I gotta
say guys as an engineer
at some level you can measure the boy
with a logic analyzer whatever you can
measure the voltage without screwing up
the circuit at some level I don't
understand what you're saying
if one day we establish consciousness as
the sum of some energies within the
brain then by equals mc-squared
consciousness has a mass equivalent
that's what I'm saying okay thank you
yes sir
okay so tonight's discussion was mostly
centered upon human neuroscience for
obvious reasons but uh there was a few
mentions about neuroscience and
consciousness and whatnot of other
species and we do know that some species
are quite smart and not just like our
close relatives like you know great apes
but also you know toothed whales some
birds like parrots and crows and even I
recently saw a video that looked like it
was unedited of an elephant painting an
elephant so was it on YouTube no it was
not it was not okay as the other feather
was the elephant so P I saw Dolphin
playing chess is that real well not just
a month like Mike real question is what
my consciousness be if it has arisen in
different lineages of living things what
might consciousness be for them and also
what might it be for say a possible
alien life for you got a Hindu here
Heather yeah Heather so conscious
big-brained mammals out there well we
learn can we learn about our
consciousness by studying them you work
on lab rats to learn about work on rats
I work on him but yeah he's working
excuse me
you ever hear she said that I don't work
on rats humans yeah okay yeah we all
feel better about that yeah they're
different they're different different
IRB protocol exactly it's a protocol
that is rich to be protocol bad that's
common so what's really way there are
two different things there's
intelligence there's consciousness Abbi
can have consciousness it could feel a
sensation it could it can sense
something um it can do something very
simplistic so you don't need to be able
to play chess to be conscious we know
that in certain creatures like in
dolphins in whales and humans or certain
types of cells called spindle cells
especially in animals that are social
and that that might have some kind of
link up to awareness or at least some
kind of a self-awareness
um but until we have a fundamental
theory of what consciousness is we won't
be able to know for sure what that
something has we only can look at
behavior even with humans in the lab you
have to just ask them did you see that
or not were you aware of that or not
that's the only measure reason I saw a
comic of two dolphins
once swimming next to another and
they're referring to the humans up on
the shore and one says one dolphin says
the other they face each other and make
noises but there's no evidence they're
actually communicating yes right here
yes I have first I have to say what an
awesome panel and Bill you did great in
the debate
I'm really star struck just being here
so but anyways I want to ask to the
neuro scientists and to Neil because I
think you've been on stage I think a lot
of guys been on stage with them it's a
it's a rather controversial position
held by Sam Harris about one of my
colleagues at UCLA and I by the way I
should let me preface this by saying I
think he's a he's a brilliant order I
think he communicates very well I just
know he's got some he's a great thinker
too but it's trying to parse out whether
it's whether we agree or not or whether
there's consensus and the question is
about whether or not we have free will
oh yeah I can ask that free will so as
far as we know from nurse when if Sam
Harris recently published a tract on the
assertion that we do not have free will
and the evidence cited for it comes from
neuroscience I must answer this I have
no choice or do freewill what's up okay
know it started with um Benjamin Libet
studies in the 1980s and and all the way
until modern studies now that but the
sense of freewill is kind of an illusion
it's free will is an illusion in the
sense that your brain decides first and
you become aware of it after the fact
that we know this from a whole series of
studies from measuring your observations
even studies now where you can put
somebody in a scanner and you could
predict for example up to ten seconds
now before they're going to decide
whether to go left or right or press the
left button or right button by just
reading their brain exhibition the brain
point decides
yeah the brief or you have a readiness
potential so it kind of is gearing up
and you can start to read how the
neurons are firing in that it's going to
go sort of toward one way or another at
a certain point you can make that
prediction well before the person
becomes consciously aware that they've
decided to go left or right begin to
talk a bit yeah yeah that's a big it's
pretty well-established that yes um okay
so but does that alone negate free will
well your brain has free will presumably
the brain decides you
perception of I made the decision only
comes after the brain is already kind of
sure so we are so late I made the
decision is my brain that's I'm making
the decision Frank so let me ask you
later
okay is this phenomenon I sure hope I
don't see my keys in the trunk of my car
and close the lid on it what is that you
know what I'm talking about
you why does you know you're getting
nose in the trunk you feel that you're
gonna make a mistake but you go ahead
and make the mistake anyway so this is
this is the thing everybody's talk about
consciousness but much of our behavior
much of what we're doing is happening
outside of awareness so are over are
you're already halfway there before you
realizing oh where am I going what am i
doing and so if we had to be consciously
aware of every single move we made we
would the brain doesn't have the
capacity to do that consciousness has a
limited to capaz capacity but the
unconscious processing seems to be
unlimited which is not to say we also
couldn't call that free will right in an
unconscious way you're obviously yes or
unconsciously making decisions freely
all the time particularly I only have
time for two more questions I'm sorry
for the rest of the line there sir okay
well I see someone really young in the
line there oh but sir I'm not referring
to you okay that mean I will take the
last two here and just one more over
there sir okay the question is kind of
following up on the issue of awareness
and heightened awareness and the use of
psychotropic drugs in a hallucinogenics
in treatment of brain disorders oh okay
yeah so and what I have one other
question how many people on the panel
are left-handed well get rid of them no
no once again
uh left-handed people have certain
advantages certain things well you add
the hilarious old joke you want your kid
to grow up to be a left-handed relief
pitcher because he or she is going to
let so far make more money actually
people who are left-handed have less
lateralization so language tends to be
more lateral it's not completely in the
left brain but there lateralization
learn more activate like more activation
in one hemisphere of the brain than the
other so like language tends to be
lateral eyes or there's motivation in
the left hemisphere but people who are
left-handed there tends to be more
activation in the right hemisphere above
and beyond those who are right-handed so
there's less lateralization there's more
sort of distributed across the brain
activation I'm about 20% left-handed but
the point of a psychic is that this
actually it's like a trip for the drugs
to treatment there were actually now
studies at where I'm at they're using
ketamine's as a treatment for depression
which used to be a club drug called
Special K and if you take too much of it
you can dissociate it's not good we're
doing that later in the name of science
yeah hey thank all you guys like want to
dissociate later I've got some special
okay but I think also a treatment for
depression that's it's sort of one set
but there also there is a field that's
looking at sort of understanding altered
states of consciousness and our
perception of altered states of
consciousness probably beyond the scope
and even using drugs like ecstasy for
therapy and treatment for PTSD their
therapeutic Li with with sort of well
trained and and and very elaborate
supervision it can be very helpful
supervision again we read
just a quick follow-up on that I Heather
is there any mental state beyond the one
that is alert and bright that can be
chemically induced that is a greater
mental state of awareness than the one
you started with so because it appears
that every time you do anything chemical
to the brain it disrupts your ability to
know what reality is no no go ahead
the first of all even just in our non
drug-induced State our perception is
different than what's necessarily out
there in reality sure there's all sorts
of illusions you don't see what's right
in front of your oh yes yeah yeah so
there's that so anytime you but add a
certain kind of chemical you change the
the neural chemistry of the brain it's
not going to say that you're going to be
more aware you're just going to have a
different type of awareness and
perception when you have things like
synesthesia when you have senses
crossing from LSD those kinds of
experiences you know these are these are
kind of qualitative or quantitative
questions right yes you're having more
experiences that are much more
complicated and much more you know the
trippy than what we're experiencing
efficient our new orleans state but i
think you know well yeah that's
subjective you've read about these
conditions I have yeah yeah like me well
my follow-up question is the way you see
it's like really red red it's like the
same uh last question yeah this side of
the eye being pressure for the last
question something I've always been
fascinated with you guys talked about
like telekinesis mind-reading and all
that where does deja boo' fall into the
spectrum we've all experienced it we've
all had that moment or many moments that
we know what's coming but we don't know
why have you asked this before
I got I waited for one of you I'm sorry
it's only because I had already heard us
night uh have you heard George Carlin
comment on danger he says he ever walked
into a room and you were sure it has
never happened to you before that this
was who shot dad but so so deja vu a
week what do you guys say about that um
so I I'm not an expert in this area but
I think that there's a sense that you
something is triggered in the brain
where you get a sense of familiarity and
then you attribute that to what's
happening around you and there's also
studies that show when you lose that
sense of familiarity some people think
that a person they know very well is an
impostor so they think like their
husband or wife is an alien because they
lose the sense of familiarity but and
sometimes the familiar that that same
neural circuit is activated in any
situation and they feel like they've
been there before they and that's I
think that's sort of speaking to the
sort of redundancy that occurs in the
brain that the notion is that there
there are many ways to get to one
destination and sometimes pathways get
triggered that have this sort of this
sense of familiarity because you've
you've literally activated a pathway
that is redundant I mean everything's
got to fit in there sure there's miles
and miles and miles but there are
certain things that are going to trigger
redundant kind of pathways that also
again have that sense of I've done this
before and your brain thinks it has yeah
and also the other thing with that
memories are or malleable each time you
remember something you can reconstruct
it it's different than the memory of
your iPhone the picture that you look at
will stay the same you know 10,000 years
now that picture will be exactly the
same but every time you remember
something it slightly changes so we can
rewrite history in a way uh the last
question of the evening yes if someone
was born in space how would that affect
the way on their brain develops
well clay told you know you're 9 it's
past my bedtime
it has your bedtime when you see your
parents let them know they're
irresponsible as you drove here child
genius so first that's a brilliant
question first of all second I can take
it only so far maybe heather has and and
and my um have some other comments on
that but there are a lot of things in
our lives that you know we were evolved
to be on earth with our force of gravity
and the kind of light that's here and so
there all these things that shape what
eventually we call common sense and
things fall down when you let go of them
fact the act of saying let go means to
drop it whereas in space letting go
doesn't drop it it just sort of stays
there so your awareness of what is
normal is really different and we don't
really know it's it's kind of unethical
at this point to just do that experiment
set set up let's see what happens to my
kid after she's born in zero-g you know
so so we don't really know but there
from the experiments done there are
things about your ears inside your ear
you get a sense of balance okay your
ears tell it's oh job to say at the
fitness center I do that little balance
thing so you doing this alright so your
bet your sense of balance comes about
because you're in a gravity field if you
got born in space and that's all you
know and then we put you here on earth
Hevy did you see the end of the movie
gravity in it in it Sandra Bullock who's
been a long time in space
she only accurate part of it she crawls
up on the beach and she realizes she
hasn't had to walk in a long time her
sense of balance had grown accustomed to
being in zero-g
and had forgotten what it was like to
walk on earth dr. t I got it I gotta
interject this do it you don't know that
don't know what you don't know that if a
kid were born in space that he or she
came back to earth couldn't figure it
out you don't know I hear she may have
actually a whole different deeper
understanding of inertia and physics and
friction that I admit we don't want to
run that test he's Uncle Bill is right
we don't know okay put on clothes this
guesses Sandra Bullock yeah your best
evidence is what happened at the end of
the movie gravity that's this house
thank you all for coming to start our
let's get Michael KITT
yeah this is Startalk